700.000 Todesopfer pro Jahr fordern Superkeime
schon jetzt - und die Zahl steigt, so eine
Statistik der Weltgesundheitsorganisation
WHO in die Millionen. Multiresistente Keime,
die immun gegen verschiedene Klassen von Antibiotika
sind, gehören wohl mit zu den größten Gefahren
für die Menschheit in unserer Zeit! Eine
Entdeckung im arktischen Spitzbergen macht
jetzt deutlich, dass die Gene dieser Superkeime
vor nichts Halt machen und keineswegs auf
die menschliche Zivilisation angewiesen sind.
Und schon heute wissen wir wieviele Millionen
in naher Zukunft daran sterben werden! Clixoom
Science & Fiction - hier gibt es jeden Tag
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts! - herzlich willkommen!
Wir alle wissen: Vor allem in Krankenhäusern
sind Superkeime eine große Gefahr. Doch wie
verbreitet sind die multiresistenten Keime?
Dazu gibt es bislang nicht wirklich aussagekräftige
Untersuchungen. Auch, wenn sie bislang nicht
nur in Tieren und Menschen, sondern beispielsweise
auch in Meeressedimenten und Böden aufgespürt
werden konnten. Doch der spektakuläre Fund
eines britischen Forschungsteams macht jetzt
klar, dass die Gene derjenigen Keime, die
solche Resistenzen übertragen, nicht im geringsten
auf menschliche Zivilisation angewiesen sind.
Denn die britischen Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler fanden insgesamt 131 100 verschiedene
Resistenzgene im arktischen Boden nahe Spitzbergen.
Dabei handelt es sich um Gene, die Bakterien
die Immunität gegen Antibiotika verleihen.
Aufgespürt in einem eigentlich unberührtes
Ökosystem. Doch selbst dort gibt es offenbar
kein Entkommen! Klar ist, dass sich solche
Resistenzgene leicht übertragen und verbreiten
können - und zwar nicht nur durch den Zellkontakt
zwischen verschiedenen Bakterien, sondern
sogar durch die Luft. Dennoch waren selbst
die Fachleute überrascht von ihrem Fund.
Dazu David Graham, einer der beteiligten Forscher
von der Newcastle University: “Die Polargebiete
gehören zu den letzten unberührten Ökosystemen
der Erde und galten daher als Orte, an denen
man noch Resistenzwerte wie vor der Ära der
Antibiotika findet.” Konkret hatten die
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler 40
Bodenproben analysiert, die vor sechs Jahren
(2013) im Nordwesten von Spitzbergen entnommen
worden waren. Durchschnittlich 66 Genvarianten
enthielt jede Bodenprobe. Dazu Graham: “Diese
Gene verleihen Schutz gegen neun verschiedene
Antibiotikaklassen, darunter die Aminoglykoside,
die Macrolide und die Beta-Lactame, die zur
Behandlung vieler Infektionen eingesetzt werden”.
Unter anderem auch dabei: das extrem gefährliche
Super-Resistenzgen mit dem Namen blaNDM-1.
Der NDM-1-Stamm wurde 2010 in Indien entdeckt
und ist nicht nur gegen alle gängigen Antibiotikaklassen
immun. Sondern auch gegen die Notfall-Antibiotika
aus der Gruppe der “Carbapeneme immun”.
Das Gen blaNDM-1 sorgt für diese extreme
Resistenz - gegen diese Erreger hilft tatsächlich
nur noch das giftige Colistin mit teils starken
Nebenwirkungen. Diese Entdeckung des Forschungsteam
zeigt, wie sich sich solche Resistenzen ausbreiten
- und das zudem auch noch weltweit und zwar
auch in solch entlegene Winkel der Erde wie
eben Spitzbergen. Auch die Geschwindigkeit,
mit der sich blaNDM-1 ausgebreitet hat, erstaunt
das Forschungsteam sehr. Dazu Graham: “Weniger
als drei Jahre, nachdem blaNDM-1 erstmals
in indischen Städten nachgewiesen wurde,
finden wir es nun tausende von Kilometer entfernt
– in einer Region, die bisher kaum vom Menschen
beeinflusst wurde. Das zeigt, wie schnell
und weitreichend sich die Antibiotika-Resistenzen
inzwischen ausgebreitet haben.”. Nach Ansicht
des Forschungsteams haben höchstwahrscheinlich
Zugvögel die resistenten Keime nach Spitzbergen
gebracht. Diese haben sie wohl in südlicheren
Regionen beim Überwintern aufgenommen, diese
dann in die Arktis eingeschleppt und über
ihren Kot freigesetzt. Fest steht jedenfalls:
Die weltweite Verbreitung solcher multiresistenter
Keime ist eine ernstzunehmende und tödliche
Bedrohung für uns. Und das Problem ist menschengemacht.
Dazu Graham: "Was die Menschen durch den übermäßigen
Einsatz von Antibiotika auf globaler Ebene
getan haben, ist die Beschleunigung der Evolutionsrate
und die Schaffung einer neuen Welt resistenter
Stämme, die es nie zuvor gegeben hat.”
Das Fatale daran: Dass Bakterien eine Resistenz
gegen Antibiotika entwickeln - das war eigentlich
abzusehen. Denn das folgt ganz den Mechanismen
der Evolution: Diejenigen Organismen, die
sich ihrer Umwelt am besten anpassen, überleben
und können sich vermehren. Durch zufällige
Veränderungen in ihrem Erbgut kam es also,
dass vereinzelte Bakterien weniger empfindlich
auf das angewandte Antibiotikum reagieren
haben. Diese konnten sich dann vermehren und
haben so ihre Unempfindlichkeit an die nächste
Bakterien-Generation weitergegeben. Ihnen
hat zudem in die Karten gespielt, dass in
den letzten Jahren immer häufiger Antibiotika
eingesetzt wurden - sowohl bei uns Menschen
selbst als auch bei Tieren. Zu dem verschwenderischen
Einsatz von Antibiotika in der Massentierhaltung
kommt oft auch noch eine fehlerhafte Anwendung
- auch bei uns Menschen. Eine zu kurze Einnahmedauer
gilt beispielsweise als Grund dafür, dass
sich einige Bakterien tatsächlich so verändern
konnten, dass sie fast gegen alle gängigen
Antibiotika resistent geworden sind. Also
nur nochmal zum Verständnis: In der Massentierhaltung
werden ständig dauerhaft Antibiotika als
Vorsorge gegeben. Das ist eine absolute Katastrophe.
Bei uns Menschen ist eine ebensolche Katastrophe,
wenn wir die Antibiotika nicht bis zur eltzten
Tablette nehmen, dann bleiben resitente Keime
übrig, die bei den nächsten Menschen töten
können. Und so kommt es immer öfter vor,
dass gängige Antibiotika versagen und Ärzte-Teams
nicht mehr wissen, wie sie Patienten helfen
können. Der Worst-Case! Denn Studien zufolge
sterben schon jetzt jährlich weltweit 700.000
Menschen an Infektionen durch medikamenten-resistente
Keime. Bis 2050 könnte diese Zahl auf zehn
Millionen Opfer steigen wohlgemerkt pro Jahr.
Dies sind die Hochrechnungen einer britischen
Expertengruppe im Auftrag der britischen Regierung.
Und das hieße dann: Mehr Tote durch resistente
Erreger als durch Krebserkrankungen. Mehr
zum Thema gibt es hier: Wie wir selber Superbakterien
züchten bei Doktor Whatson. Unbedingt ansehen
und abonnieren!